[Music]
so the question is can distributed
ledger technology can blockchain
technology be used to fight fake news
right and I you know it's funny I view
distributed ledger technology is the
closest thing we have in the technology
field to being able to say something is
a fact right
they've we've recorded a Bitcoin
transaction right essentially we have an
entire network witnessing that I have
sent you you know some number of Bitcoin
right or some number of a digital asset
a huge number and now I can't deny that
I made that transaction and you can't
deny that I made that transaction right
and that there's that that is a really
powerful thing in a way it's it's kind
of like the Wikipedia when somebody puts
something in there and everyone has seen
that and if it's wrong it gets removed
that's something as well that's coming
to be accepted as as factual right and
so I think the possibility of using
distributed Ledger's to record data that
is of a really high quality because it's
being recorded when it happens is being
witnessed by a large number of people
who and and thus made undeniable
immutable in this ledger right we can we
have a chance at creating a body of data
that can come to be trusted in a way
that data normally can't think about the
debate over climate change right there's
not only been attacks on do you have the
right weather model you know are you
really showing this but but attacks on
the fundamental collection of that data
in the first place right imagine if
instead of debating whether you know you
had the right data or I had the right
data or a piece of data goes missing or
an entire data set goes missing when
there's a change in political
administration let's say right instead
of that imagine if instead you know we
had weather sensors and air quality
sensors on you know a hundred rooftops
in every major capital around the world
right collecting this data and
publishing it to a public ledger right
that data would never go away it would
only go away that well you know if every
single server in this network were to
disappear one day right and that
permanence that history and the
integrity of that data because it's it's
sick it's signed and it's validated as
part of this distributed ledger I would
turn it into an immutable set of facts
really it was this temperature in New
Delhi on that date at that time as
witnessed by a hundred different
witnesses there all right so that's one
way within which distributed ledger
technology might help us make sure that
we're operating from a foundation of
common common sense common factual
evidence right the next tier up though
which is really what people talk about
when they think about fake news is
analysis interpretation claims but also
rumor right when somebody hears a rumor
of something very scurrilous happening
and it correlates with what they want to
believe right chances are they'll
believe it and they'll pass it off to
their friends and so you start to see
companies like Facebook and Google and
others starting to implement systems
that when you want when you forward a
link to a friend that comes from a
source that is known to be of
questionable you know quality let's say
they'll pop up a little warning right
that says you know according to
snopes.com or according to the AP or
somebody this datum this article might
not be factual right that's something
you can do when you're a central
provider like Facebook or like Google
but wouldn't it be great to do that in a
decentralized way when somebody sends
you a news link to a website you've
never heard of before not the New York
Times not API you know or Fox News or
whatever you know where you have some
context but it's some other links
somewhere else how much should you trust
that well a lot of folks have talked
about building a distributed ledger
system for recording trust in media
sources all right so you know here's a
website here's people that we recognize
like Snopes as authorities and kind of
is something true or not but why not you
be able to publish something to that
chain as well or me that says this does
seem to be right to me this doesn't seem
to be right and then just like on
Twitter where you can choose who you
follow you could choose you know what
are these sources of authority you
choose to you want to basically that you
trust as to whether data is something is
true or not that may turn out to be an
answer to the fake news problem it may
turn out to make the different worlds
that we all live in and the bubbles we
live in even more bubblicious right but
I think there are many that hope that I
that's one way in which we can try to
fight the rumor mongering and fake news
floods that are happening on the
Internet today
[Music]
you